okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's planning committee meeting
my name is cancer richards and i will be
chairing tonight's meeting um a few
notices before we start first of all
this is um a meeting in public not a
public meeting so only those people that
have registered to speak will be
committed to do so i will call you
forward to one of the microphones in
front of you um at the appropriate time
and i'll let you know how much time you
have
and i will give you 30 second one before
that time is up once you're once that's
happened if you could stay seated for
any questions that would be really
appreciated
um if we could all members and members
of the public if you could please check
your phones now i would prefer they're
off um but i appreciate that sometimes
they're needed so at the very least if
you could turn into silence as long as
they don't disturb the flow of the
meeting uh that would be great
uh i'll do some few introductions um to
start with if i may so to my far right
we have ann banks from committee
services to my immediate right we have
mason nash who is our solicitor our
planner is ryan o'keefe and to my
immediate left is alice kosner who is
our planning manager alice i believe you
have a statement to make
i do thank you chairman my role is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision taking thank
you
marvelous thank you very much okay let's
uh let's dive into the agenda shall we
um first item is apologies for absence
and do we have any apologies please
we do chairman we've got apologies from
councillors adam curtis dixon eden
jennings and mills
marvelous thank you very much um do we
have any disclosures of interest members
counselor answer seraphim
yes chair uh disclosure of interest on
application 21
0 4 0 6 3 4.
also
other disclosure is that i know the
applicants as ex-parish councillors
okay lovely thank you very much um
remember any other disclosures
to make
no marvelous okay um so the first item
we have as our first application we have
is application2104046ful
um as you'll notice from the uh the
update sheet and also our speakers list
um we have no speakers registered on
this item so
the uh proposal is to delegate to
uh our offices um could have a second
different first of all the council
kendall um could have a show of hands
flows willing to delegate to officers
that is unanimous so committee has
resolved to delegate application twenty
one zero four 0 4 6 f u l
i don't know why i forgot the minute so
i crossed it off apologies we also have
minutes is everyone happy with the
minutes
i will sign those afters quick show
hands yeah oh we're all good yeah that's
lots and lots i do apologize i crossed
that off too quickly um okay so our
first full application and our only
application of the evening um now is
application
2104063 ful that's 15 st martin's avenue
in studly and our presentation officers
ryan o'keefe ryan over to you
thank you chairman
the application site is
uh in studly
denoted by the black dot on the map
um
the dwelling is the typical 1970s
dwelling and the proposal is for a
two-story side and rear extension and
single story rear extension
as denoted on the plans in front of you
we have some photos of the application
site and the surroundings
starting with the front elevation
to the rear
to the side and to the other neighbor
and a
photo of the street scene and the
application site denoted by the orange
arrow
and the recommendation is to grant the
application subject to conditions
brian marvis thank you very much if you
mind turning your microphone off i'd be
grateful thank you very much okay so
let's call our first speakers of the
evening who are councillor andrew
rainbow to start with please from study
parish council
good evening welcome pick any desk in
front of you whichever one you want
thank you very much and when you're
comfortable and ready to go you'll have
three minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up otherwise
the floor is yours whenever you're ready
okay thank you very much sorry i forgot
to say have you turned your microphone
on
yes button in the middle perfect over to
you thank you um
the parish council
under normal circumstances welcomes
applications which contribute to the
local environment and is aware of the
need for growing families to enlarge
their existing properties however
we feel as a parish council this needs
to be done in a harmonious way
and with considerations to local
neighbours and its locality
our objections are based around three
and two real considerations
firstly the visual impact
we believe the visual impact is
overbearing
in its current form
and being two-story which will affect
the neighboring property
which i believe is number thirteen
there is another material consideration
with the effects of light
there is significant loss of daylight to
the adjoining property
house number 13.
and my assessment stands at somewhere in
the region of
50 percent
of lights affecting uh being been
affected on the neighbouring property
due to the loss the actual loss
the third conditional uh cumulative
impact is
the overbearing density of the extension
which increases the footprints of its uh
of the existing dwelling
by some eight percent
uh therefore the actual extension is not
subservient to the existing footprints
of the
at the dwelling
we also believe that the the loss of
natural daylight
will force the neighbor to
switch his lights on his and her lights
on more frequently in their property
and with
the uh
negative impact with the energy that we
this country is currently suffering we
do believe that this could potentially
put the neighbor into some kind of
fueled poverty
in the long term
and that's all
we have to say as a parish council
wonderful thank you very much members do
we have any questions for the parish
council
no
okay uh in that case no question so uh
council rambo thank you very much for
your time and contribution this evening
while you're organizing your desk i will
call forward our next speaker who is mr
gary phillips
mr phillips you got here just in time
welcome
so when you're satin comfortable you
press the red uh press the button in the
middle it'll turn red now your
microphone will be on you'll have three
minutes and i'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up otherwise
whenever you're ready floor's yours
thank you everybody apologies for being
late uh just finished a site meeting
uh the application itself uh we've spent
quite considerable time working with
officers to try and
mitigate
residents concerns and there's been some
amendments to the single-story rear
element of the scheme it's notable that
the uh property actually faces at the
rear uh a southern aspect so it doesn't
actually overshadow
properties either side or any other
property and also the extension proposed
there are lots of presidents in the
actual road itself so i've had a look
today
uh this is a road not not that far from
where i
was born myself so i know very well and
at 24 st martins and also at number 30
there are extensions right up to the
boundary which is obviously the main
reason i believe
for opposing the application
um there is only a non-habitable window
siding onto this and if this was a new
development we would be far closer than
the sort of 2.6 2.7 meters which i
believe this extension will be
away from the actual existing
neighbouring property
so those are my comments thank you
wonderful thank you very much members do
we have any questions for our
applicant's agent cancer crumb
hello mr phillips um
i didn't quite catch it at the start you
said you spoke to somebody or or you
revised your plans after speaking to
somebody or did i mishear that
we spoke to the planning officer so
there was some consultation where
uh ryan o'keefe tried to liaise with i
believe the residents and also
councillors to try and see whether we
could reach a compromise
so the roof for instance on the single
story element
rather than being a lean-to roof which
would have had a effectively a a wedge
that was
uh
i suppose siding onto the neighbor we've
made that a hipped roof so obviously the
impact is far less on the adjoining
semi-detached property so that that was
probably the main change thank you
thank you any other questions members
no in that case mr phillips thanks very
much for your time and contribution this
evening
so our final speaker of the evening's
council andrew serafin cancer come on
down
and you know the drill you'll have five
minutes i'll give you 30 second morning
before the end whenever you're ready the
floor is yours
okay thank you chip
um i've supported many applications
similar to this but not quite on the
scale
and the ones i've supported
have an entry
they are not built on the boundary
um
i did go down and measure the stagger of
the two houses between number 15 and 13.
and it on the front it's 2.1 meters
not 1.9 meters as the case officer
says now this extension down the side
looks as though it extends past
the number 13 by another two meters
so you've got four meters
overall
bigger than the house next door in depth
this i feel
is overbearing
light loss
and the footprint of the
application to build this extension
is too great for this type of house in
the vicinity
as most houses are three bedroom houses
uh
quite simply i've spoken to the
neighbours and
they are a bit distraught having this
built on the boundary
so quite simply
i asked
committee members to reject this as
being overbearing and too large on the
plot of land okay thank you
thank you very much members do you have
any questions for counseling suffering
no in that case cancer hence sharon
thank you very much for your time
contribution
okay we have no more speakers so let's
move to points of clarification to our
officers does anyone have anything
they'd like clarifying councillor
fleming
um just a question for the officer when
we have extensions
in semi-detached houses built up to a
borderline
occasionally when the people next door
say they'd like to extend to the to the
boundary line the overhang on the
soffits
and the overhang on the roof we end up
with a clash i've had the same system
i've had the situation a couple of times
when you say build up to the to the
border line and you mean that the
footings are going to be on the border
line
or the soffits on the roof are going to
be on the border line because again if
if you build the bricks up to the thing
the roof overhangs into next door space
so if you get a similar situation next
door you've got a clash problem so um
whereabouts are we with that
the plans indicate to me um that the
built
form to the boundary will be all uh the
construction so up to the soffit
and not just the footings themselves
anyone else before i have my quick one
um ryan i see you've
obviously covered on page 22 the 45 25
degree rule we we heard uh from i think
constantin that uh his view is number 13
sits further back is deeper
in here it suggests that the
sorry that this proposal would be deeper
than the neighbors um on your uh report
it's just the neighbors is deeper i'm
confused which one it is could you show
me and and have you got a diagram
that'll show the 45 25 angles so we know
that no windows and lots of light is
going to occur
please
so the 4 525 was taken from the
as submitted location plan on
the application
um
so the adjoining neighbor
which is number
um
let me go right
it goes
it's the one to the south of the red
line isn't it as we're looking at it now
so the one below it that one there that
one there yeah um so
both 45 25 were taken from both
neighbors um to see the impact of the
extension
and it was obviously the extension
the neighbor adjoining
the application property where the 45
was breached
but the 45 was not breached by
the neighbor indicated by the arrow
okay so ultimately you're absolutely
satisfied you have conducted that 45-25
tour you're absolutely satisfied that
there will be no loss of likes of the
neighboring property yeah um and
therefore you're that's what why you've
come to the conclusion you have yeah
ultimately if i can just clarify one
thing um just in terms of loss of like
there are two windows on the side
elevation of number 13. so that's the
dwelling to the south but the ground
floor is a secondary window to a kitchen
so a non-hub so essentially the loss of
light to it does not just fire refusal
and the first floor window is a hallway
so not a habitable window so any loss of
light again doesn't justify refusal so i
don't think it's what we're saying that
there's not going to be any loss of
light it's just that the loss of light
isn't going to justify in our minds a
refusal planning position
according to the policy it doesn't
breach any of those like rules
correct good
okay um does anyone else have any
questions before we move to the debates
no let's move to debate who would like
to kick us off
i'm going to start pointing fingers
counselor kendall seems to be waving
um
yeah i think if we're looking at
i don't obviously i don't understand
that you know i've seen this sort of
thing in my own ward in wellsport where
um
houses do get much bigger and expand out
sideways and parish councils get upset
and get worried about the nature of
terracing um i sort of i sort of
understand that
but what point i'm coming from on this
is really
it's not breaking our policy so i i
don't see that it's actually going to
cause a terracing effect because that
would require all of the houses in that
road to do that and i don't think that's
likely
um beyond that i don't really see the
loss of light as an issue again because
as we've just said in our policy i don't
think that's actually it well it's
allowed by our policy there will be some
loss of light that is allowed by our
policy i can't find any substantial
planning grounds to go against the
officer's recommendation so for that
reason i'm happy to propose that we
grant
thank you for the recommendation thank
you very much cancer kendall uh anyone
else
council crump
uh thank you mr chairman um
i'd say it's
uh again um i must admit i've seen
similar
potentially better
extensions than this
and perhaps things should could have
been done slightly differently
but i think councillor kendall
knocked it on the head
to say that i can't see any significant
planning
reasons to refuse this application
so
um did you propose because i'll be happy
to second the proposal to
to grant that it's not the best one but
again looking at
the information in front of us listening
to the presentation
i'm finding it difficult to find a
material reason to
refuse this application thank you very
much cancer crumb anyone else before we
move to a vote
no in that case we have a proposal to
grant uh it has been seconded so um for
could i see a show of hands for those in
favor of granting application twenty one
zero four zero six three ful uh in
london's office recommendation
that is unanimous so uh committee
therefore resolves to grant application
twenty one zero four zero six three four
fifteen martin's avenue in studly
do we have any urgent business
no no urgent business
so thank you very much for everyone for
assembling and your time contributions
this evening
i'll declare the meeting close thank you
you